Okay, a little bit of a problem.
We went to the wrong airport.
And now we're all jumping in five different cabs
and rushing to Conan Town.
Be there soon.
Very nice to meet you.
It's an honor.
Honor.
Hi, how are you?
This is the Bill Nye of Japan.
Very good.
During the Bush to the Clinton.
Oh, Bush to Clinton.
Yes.
You know, in America, we eventually let go of the hand.
Eventually.
You can let go at any,
it's your call.
You have.
He has a vice-like grip, and he won't...
I'm the mayor?
Yes.
I have a sash for you.
You are now Miss Iowa.
Because I am mayor for the day,
I would like to make him Conan for the day.
It's a good fit.
Excuse me?
Yes, I want to cash this check.
Tell him it's for three trillion yen.
Yes, so I would like to cash this.
No, no.
No.
I'll get you all.
I'll be back.
In a triumph of international cooperation,
the burgers came from Australia.
Courtesy of the Aussie Beef Guys.
That's all I can do in Japanese.
I traveled 6,000 miles to be here.
The mayor only traveled 25 meters.
We gather here today to agree that I am the real,
original Conan.
You have been worshiping a false god.
But I forgive you.
The mayor's hand is on my bottom.
(audience laughing)
And he's not moving it.